well president Trump has approved a
disaster declaration for parts of
Alabama devastated by Sunday's deadly
tornado outbreak that will make it
easier for those areas to get federal
aid officials have identified all 23
people killed by a twister that packed
estimated winds of 170 miles an hour
Omar Villafranca is in Smith station one
of the Alabama communities hit hard by
the storm
Omar good morning good morning this is
what 170 mile per hour winds can do to a
mobile home the woman who lived there
she got out before the tornado hit she's
accounted for the sheriff is telling us
only a handful of people are still
missing
but today we're hearing more
heartbreaking stories of loss I heard
all the kids screaming and I tried to
hold him a little tighter Jamel Hart and
her two sons Jalen and Jonathan were
visiting a cousin in Beauregard Sunday
when the twister struck the whole floor
like just snatched from unders and I
knew I was in the air Hart lost her
eight-year-old niece Mikayla Walden her
nine-year-old son Jonathan was taken to
the hospital she was with him when he
died we now know the names of all 23
people killed by Sunday's ef-4 tornado
seven of those victims are related
this sound like a train was coming alena
Smith's boyfriend is part of that family
but he survived Smith described how the
tornado just barely missed a direct hit
on her home I saw it coming and I took
off and to skip right over us
I just I'm stealing off Sheila Creech
survived hurricane Michael in October
she recently got engaged to Marshall
Lynn Grimes and they returned from a
camping trip on Sunday on Facebook
Grimes wrote for those concerned were
home safe before the storm they were
killed
hours later President Trump will be here
on Friday to surveyed the damage and so
you can see there's not much good news
here but if there's any silver lining is
that the 23 funerals will be paid for by
two unnamed companies
John it's heartbreaking Jonathan thank
you